JUST TO SHOW HOW
EXCITED PEOPLE GOT, SHOW YOU
THIS LITTLE MOMENT FROM EARLIER
ON.
AS KING CHARLES WAS GOING ALONG
THE CROWDS.
I THINK PEOPLE.
QUITE OVERCOME WITH EMOTION, AND
THEY WERE SORT OF LEANING
FORWARD TO HIM, AND THEN LOOK AT
THIS.
WAIT FOR THIS.
NOW THAT WAS JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: AND OUR PRODUCER
WENT ON AN INTREPID SEARCH TO
FIND THE PERPETRATOR OF THAT
KISS AND YOUR NAME IS JEGENEJEN.
WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN
YOU SAW THE KING?
>> I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT AND I
SAID, MAY I KISS YOU?
YES.
SO I GRABBED HIM, AND I'M VERY
HAPPY, VERY, VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SEE HIM
AND KISS HIM.
>> Reporter: HOW DID YOU FEEL
WHEN YOU SAW HIM?
WHY DID YOU WANT TO DO THAT?
>> I LOVE THE ROYAL FAMILY.
ALWAYS I'M WATCHING THEM, BY THE
VENEER, FROM SMALL BABY TO
GROWING UP.
>> Reporter: DID YOU EVER THINK
YOU'D KISS A KING ON THE LIPS?
>> NO.
NO!
NEVER CROSSED MY MIND.
>> Reporter: HE LOOKED RELAXED.
DIDN'T HE?
CONSIDERING WHAT HE'S BEEN
THROUGH?
>> YES.
HE LOOKED SAD.
LOOKED SAD.
I SAY, MAY I KISS YOU, AND HE
SAID, YEAH.
>> Reporter: AND WHY ARE YOU
DOING THAT?
COMFORT HIM?
REASSURE HIM OR JUST A FEELING
THAT OVERCAME YOU?
>> YES.
JUST A FEELING, ACTUALLY.
OH, MY GOD.
IN THE FRONT, YES.
>> Reporter: VERY HEARTENING FOR
HIM TO SEE THE REACTION FROM THE
CROWDS THERE.
THE WARMTH.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: DID YOU GET A SENSE
IT WAS COMFORTING FOR HIM?
>> I THINK SO, YEAH, BECAUSE HE
WAS -- SMILING.
HE DIDN'T SAY LIKE -- LOVELY AND
STARTED SMILING.
>> Reporter: SHOWS HE'S NOT AT
UP TIGHT AS PEOPLE EXPECT A KING
TO BE.
NOT AS NERVOUS.
HE'S NOT AT --
>> NO, NO.
HE'S PERFECT.
>> Reporter: HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE HIM?
>> LOVELY.
HE'S PERFECT.
I'M ALWAYS LIKING HIM.
>> Reporter: WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
>> I COME FROM SIDE AND FROM
GREECE.
>> Reporter: PRINCE OF GREECE.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: YOU FEEL LIKE
KINSHIP?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: WHAT WAS THE
ATMOSPHERE LIKE OUT THERE
AMONGST THE CROWDS?
>> IT'S OKAY.
EVERYBODY HAPPY.
YEAH.
EVERYBODY --
>> Reporter: JENNY, YOU'RE GOING
VIRAL AS WE SPEAK.
>> AND THE OTHER DAY, IT JUST --
CALLED FAMILY.
>> Reporter: YOUR SON, WHAT DID
HE SAY?
>> HE SAID, I'M BUSY NOW.
>> Reporter: THERE'S A STORY TO
TELL THE REST OF THE FAMILY.
>> YES.
I'M VERY HAPPY.
>> Reporter: JENNY VIDEO NOW
WORLD FAMOUS.
BACK TO YOU GUYS.
>> I'LL TELL YOU, AS JOURNALISTS
THERE ARE TIMES YOU'RE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO WITNESS HISTORIC,
MEMORABLE MOMENTS, IN THE
MOMENT, AND I THINK THAT WAS
JUST ONE OF THEM.
CERTAINLY THE BIGGER PICTURE.
THE NEW KING GREETING THE CROWD,
BUT I THINK WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT --
>> THE KISS FOR THE HISTORY
BOOKS.
>> JENNY'S KISS SEEN AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND CNN MATTHEW CHANCE ALSO IN
LONDON.
DOWN DO
DOWNTOWN LONDON.
JUST DOWN THE STREET FROM
BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM THE
PEOPLE?
>> Reporter: YEAH THAT'S RIGHT,
JIM.
IN FACT, YOU CAN SEE BUCKINGHAM
PALACE IN THE DISTANCE BEHIND
ME.
THIS IS THE SORT OF RED PAVED
AVENUE WHICH LEADS RIGHT UP TO
THAT MAIN ROYAL RESIDENCE UP
THERE, AND YOU CAN SEE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, THAT ARE
TAKING SOME TIME OUT OF THEIR
DAY TO GO TOWARDS THE GATES OF
BUCKINGHAM PALACE WHERE THEY
CAN, YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY THERE TO
MEET KING CHARLES III, AS WE'VE
JUST SEEN SOME OF THEM DOING,
BUT ALSO TO PAY THEIR RESPECTS
TO QUEEN ELIZABETH II, OF
COURSE, WHO PASSED AWAY
YESTERDAY.
IT'S INTERESTING FOR ME, BECAUSE
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THIS MORNING, AND I HAVE TO SAY.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF DIVISION
BETWEEN THE LEVEL OF SADNESS
THAT PEOPLE ARE EXPRESSING.
I MEAN, THERE'S A GENERAL SADS
IN, OF COURSE.
PEOPLE ARE VERY AFFECTIONIST
TOWARDS QUEEN ELIZABETH AND SAD
TO SEE HER GO, BUT WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO THE OLDER PEOPLE, OLDER
GENERATIONS HERE, THEY'RE VERY
MUCH REMINDED THIS IS A PERSON
VERY MUCH ICONIC, WITH THEM MOST
OF THEIR LIVES, ALL OF THEIR
LIVES IN MANY CASES AND HAVE
KNOWN NO ONE ELSE.
SO THE QUEEN OCCUPIED THIS
INCREDIBLY ICONIC AND UNIQUE
POSITION IN BRITISH SOCIETY.
THE YOUNGER GENERATION OF, YOU
KNOW, GENERAL, UNSCIENTIFIC
STRAW POLL, ALSO HAD AFFECTION
TOWARDS THE QUEEN, BUT OBVIOUSLY
SHE'S NOT PLAYED QUITE AS BIG A
ROLE IN THEIR LIVES AS, YOU
KNOW, THE PEOPLE IN THEIR 60s,
70s AND 80s.
SO I THINK THERE'S A DIMINISHING
AMOUNT OF, YOU KNOW, SENSE THAT
SHE EMBODIES THE PEOPLE, AND,
YOU KNOW, BUT I THINK WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THAT EVEN THOUGH
THE ACCESSION OF THE THRONE HAS
BEEN AUTOMATIC, FROM ELIZABETH
TO CHARLES, THE TRANSMISSION OF
THE AUTHORITY AND OF THE RESPECT
THE QUEEN HAS ISN'T NECESSARILY
AUTOMATIC.
SO THAT'S WHY IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT SEEKING KING CHARLES
III OUT TODAY RECEIVING A VERY
WARM WELCOME FROM CROWDS.